Who do you trust with
your deepest hurts,
your most painful truths?
And what will you do
if you found out
that your most trusted
ally was lying to you?
(dramatic music)
This season, Poppy
is experiencing things
still residual from season one.
It's her personal life
that is a part of
the case itself
that needs to be solved.
All of Poppy's personal
relationships
are being affected by her
needing to deal
with what is damaging her.
Everyone's dealing
with something
that they're carrying
in their life
that's either holding them back
or has held them back
or that they're still
deeply struggling with.
(dramatic music)
People are drawn to people
with flaws.
Drama is about imperfection.
Something's perfect,
then who cares, right?
It's the moments in between.
The damaged people
are so delicious
and it's so much fun
to watch them
as they dig inside and
grapple with their truth.
(sirens wailing)
There's no one that is
unscathed by
humanity and earth and
the world that itself.
I think people really can
delve into who these
characters are.
You can relate to the pain
of the damage
that's been inflicted
upon that person.
There's a lot that we're
dealing with on this show.
A lot of, lot of conflicts.
(dramatic music)
(screaming)
In trying to find out
what happened to Joshua,
we find out more about
this deep love
that these women have
for each other,
that's also hiding
a lot of secrets.
(dramatic music)
It's a very complex
world that Michelle's created,
but a really beautiful
one, really textured one.
There are no heroes
and that's what makes them real.
And that's what makes them
interesting.
I knew better than to
expect anything from anyone.
The beauty of what it means
to find those very difficult,
emotional, deep layers that not
only are in the writing,
but also within myself.
(dramatic music)
It's all about what's
underneath.
We are constantly forcing
each other to be truthful
and we're always holding back.
When we don't deal with
our childhood traumas,
they do become the demons that
hold us hostage as adults.
I love you Micah.
I love you too.
I don't think she's afraid
what she'll discover
about Micah,
I think she's more afraid
of what she'll discover about
herself.
(dramatic music)